when you think of great films you might
think of their directors like Spielberg
Hitchcock peel or actors like Meryl
Streep Viola Davis Morgan Freeman but
recently there's a new name in the mix
and it's not a person but a studio a24
[Music]
824 movies have been nominated for over
50 Oscars and have won 16. they've taken
over Halloween and maybe your closet and
the reason why you know their name is
part of their strategy a strategy that's
helped take a24 from a tiny Distribution
Company to making some of the biggest
and weirdest movies and TV shows of the
past 10 years
[Music]
maybe seen maybe more a24 films than the
people who work at 8 24. my name is Nate
Jones I'm a senior writer for vulture in
New York Magazine last August 8 24 I
ranked all of them from worst to best
the company was founded on two sort of
basic creative principles the first was
that they were going to give directors
an almost unprecedented creative freedom
and then to pay for that because that is
you know creatively risky they basically
decided that they weren't going to be
spending money on traditional forms of
marketing they were going to try and use
viral marketing and Word of Mouth these
cheaper ways of gaining attention to
their movies
for the first half of their existence
they only bought they didn't make any of
the films
in other words 824 was founded as a
Distribution Company and as your
resident film there to have to give you
a quick lesson on the movie making
pipeline for this all to make sense so
bear with me for a second
first there's production where the movie
gets made then there's distribution
where a company buys the rights to
finish film and takes on the work of
marketing it and making deals to connect
it to companies that can show it to
audiences that's the third part known as
exhibition where companies like movie
theaters and streaming services show
movies for the general public the
studios are likely familiar with
generally take on both production and
distribution so something like Indiana
Jones and the dial of Destiny is
produced by Disney and then Disney also
makes the trailers posters and deals
with exhibitors like AMC and Regal to
get that movie shown in theaters but
smaller independently produced films
often go to film festivals like Sundance
or Tribeca in hopes of getting the
attention of a distributor who will buy
the rights of the film and will help
them make those connections
in the beginning a24's sole Focus was to
find great Indie movies and buy the
distribution rights for them it's just
easier that way you don't need as much
money you know it takes a lot of cash to
produce a film doesn't take as much to
just buy a film that's already made
let's use Spring Breakers their first
hit as a case study to show how all
their strategies come together Spring
Breakers was the first a24 film I saw it
was the first 824 film most people saw I
think it was a very good introduction to
the a24 style the film has an extremely
strong artistic vision from director
Harmony Karine who a24 courted by making
bespoke gun-shaped bongs
the movie had striking visual choices
like this rain that almost looks like
blood and a neon color palette that has
become a staple of a24 films it had a
clear hook you have these sort of Disney
starlets like Selena Gomez and they're
you know getting up to no good and doing
drugs and if you were a young person
who'd grown up on the Disney Channel
suddenly all these people you'd seen in
this very squeaky clean entertainment
were getting very rough and grimy and on
top of that it had supremely nameable
sequences James Franco has you know the
first of many a24 scenes that would just
become this sort of perfect little
tidbit he is the speech look at my
I got I got shorts every color
Scarface on repeat it was just this this
weird sort of thing that that really
yeah just caught on
their Innovative online marketing
strategy leverage gifs and memes to make
the movie Buzzy like this one that
amassed over 20 000 thumbs up on
Facebook which
you know doesn't sound like a lot now
but you gotta remember this was 2013
back when the LA Times was calling likes
thumbs UPS anyways the marketing worked
the movie ended up setting per screen
attendance records for its opening
weekend as well as clocking the biggest
premiere of a movie in limited release
that year
the second weekend everybody talked a
lot about how they hated the movie but
their first weekend was incredible that
movie was a huge Word of Mouth hit if
you look at like how much money it made
compared to other films you know it
doesn't really stand out but if you look
at how much money it makes compared to
other you know independent films from
that era like it was a huge hit and
crucially it proved that the a24 method
worked if they could keep curating
distinct vibey movies marketing them
online for less money and more virality
and distributing them in a way where the
box office can rival the budget then
they were in business and oh boy were
they in business
they were able to create such a strong
brand you knew in your head kind of what
an a24 film was and I think that's down
to their sense of taste and I don't know
of any other Studio that has such an
almost like personal style in that way
they helped launch careers for ariaster
the Daniels and Robert Eggers and
afforded directorial debuts to Greta
Greg Jonah Hill and Bo Burnham they
would find these up and coming directors
and be like we are going to sort of
Usher you to the next level ex machina
showed their shrewdness in marketing as
they created a Tinder account for Alicia
vikander's lead character inviting men
to watch the movie and films like room
became big hits at the Oscars
they won their first Oscars in 2016.
they won best actors for Brie Larson in
room they won best visual effects for ex
machina and they won best documentary
for Amy so they were they had been on
the scene they had been respected they'd
sort of known how to play the industry
game you know they weren't too cool for
it they weren't holding their heads
above it and four years in after
curating a strong brand off of other
people's movies they decided to produce
one on their own so Moonlight was the
first film that they made themselves it
was a bet on Barry Jenkins who had made
only one other feature and at eight
years before at this point and they
basically said like we will let you do
totally whatever you want we will
support you visually it does look a lot
like other 824 films you know you have
that neon you have that very subjective
lighting Moonlight that was when they
get their reputation I think for like oh
you know it's it's not just online hype
they're not just like Buzzy they are
going to release some great great films
if you look at the films they have
produced since Moonlight it's a lot of
the movies we think of as like Barry a24
on cut gems it's everything everywhere
all at once you know it's these movies
that are these big bold brand statements
in 2017 they expanded to TV when you
talk to people who watch Euphoria a lot
of them don't know that it's an a24
series because Euphoria Arizona HBO
which is a very strong brand a very big
brand and that kind of crowds out the
a24 of it all but beef airs on Netflix
which has a much smaller brand and you
know suddenly that allows the a24 of it
all to kind of jump out and as a cherry
on top they make merch for themselves
not just for the films you know they
will sell a24 t-shirts and a24 hoodies
with that little logo on it and that
sort of you know helps build that sort
of cult around this you know editorial
sensibility that they have and they
employ a lot of the techniques that the
fashion industry tests do you know they
will do collaborations with you know
online Ceramics they will do limited
edition drops where you know you've got
to get your hands on something now they
build this sense of exclusivity around
it where it becomes you know their their
a24 merch heads you know we're really
hoping to get you know the latest stuff
and something that no other Indie Studio
has quite managed to pull off
when you look at their trajectory in
retrospect it's easy to be dazzled into
thinking that they've got the Midas
touch and in some ways they do but you
know we don't need to build them up too
much like any student they make bad
films too you just might not notice it
because a24 puts out a ton of movies
every year as compared to other Studios
both big and small in 2022 the studio
put out 20 films that's two more than
Paramount a studio that's way larger
than they are but they have a unique way
of hiding their bad films and making
them go away they had to deal with
DirecTV they now have a deal with Apple
TV where you know movies that maybe they
don't think are quite past muster
they'll just go straight there you know
those ones won't play at the Metro graph
those ones won't be playing it you know
your cool Indie theater they will kind
of
quietly shuffled off to you know DirecTV
maybe people will find them but if
people don't find them you know maybe
that's okay too you look at the list of
a24 films there's dozens of them that
you have never heard of that nobody has
ever heard of the Adderall Diaries the
kill team Revenge of the Green dragons
these are movies that truly do not exist
the steps don't seem to matter much when
their tried and true strategies creates
such big wins when I talk to the fans
last year you know someone readily
admitted oh yeah like I'm in the cult
I'm deep in the cult and when I ask like
what I asked them why the key thing was
difference there's so much these days
that feels sort of the same feels very
corporate very controlled now that was
kind of the one thing that they all kind
of agreed on is that like when they go
see an a24 film you know it might be
good there's a chance it might be
terrible but you know they know it's
going to be just like a little weirder a
little more offbeat ideally it's going
to be something they haven't seen before
the name means nothing the name is
there's no symbolism the name is an
Italian Highway that leads out of Rome
that I think Katz was driving on and he
was like oh that would be a good name
for a company but it sort of fits right
because it's abstract and sort of
mysterious and you're like oh there must
be a hidden meaning there you know I
often like some of the films you know
you're like you know there must be
something there it Sparks your curiosity
in a way